thanks Sarah now I'm going to use git
branches to create an experimental
change in the asteroids repository this
game is pretty hard and I don't want to
change that but I'd also like to create
an easier version of the game if I do
there will be two versions of the game
that are almost exactly the same but
with some slight differences so this is
a great time to create a branch now
there's a lot of ways I could make this
game easier but here's one every time I
shoot an asteroid it breaks into three
smaller fragments I'll try making it
easier to complete the level by only
making it break into two each time I
don't want to make this change on the
master branch though since I don't
consider it an unofficial update to the
game instead I'll create a branch called
easy mode for that change I can use the
command git branch to create and view
branches first I'll run git branch with
no arguments which shows me my current
branches right now the only branch is
master which is the default branch now
I'll run git branch easy mode when I
give an argument to get branch it
creates a new branch with that name so
now when I run git branch again I can
see that the easy mode branch was
created this star next to master means
that master is the branch that is
currently checked out so that's the one
that will update if I make a change
that's not what I want
I want the easy mode label to update
when I make a change and master to stay
the same so I'll run the command get
check out easy mode and now when I run
get branch again I can see the easy mode
is the checked out branch since I just
created the easy mode branch it has the
same code as master right now but I'm
about to change that to make the easy
mode I'll open the file game dais I saw
earlier that the code I'm interested in
changing has a comment break into
fragments
so I'll search for fragments here I find
a loop that executes three times which
is making three smaller asteroids which
the author calls roids so I'll change
this three to a two and give the game a
try sure enough now only two smaller
asteroids form now I'd like to commit
this change even though it's only a one
character change I consider this one
logical change since it changes the
behavior of the game
and it completely accomplishes the goal
I had I'll add my change to the staging
area and then commit it and I'll use the
commit message make asteroids split into
two smaller pieces rather than three now
go ahead and create an easy mode branch
on your own computer then check out that
branch and commit a change making the
game easier you can use the same commit
that I did you can find the line that I
changed at line 678 or you can search
for break into fragments like I did when
you're finished paste the output of git
status into this box